son 200 de los 14.000 trabajadores del
ministerio de exteriores de francia pero
su protesta acerca de la jefatura de la
diplomacia francesa no ha pasado
desapercibida sobre todo porque la
última huelga de personal diplomático en
el país se remonta a 2003
es muy raro que los diplomáticos vayamos
a huelga es sólo la segunda vez en la
historia del ministerio que nos
declaramos en paro lo que significa que
realmente estamos preocupados por las
consecuencias de estas reformas posibles
afirmando
la reforma fue anunciada en abril e
implica la creación de un nuevo estatuto
de funcionario en el que los empleados
públicos no estarían atados a una
administración en particular este cambio
genera preocupación entre los empleados
de exteriores sobre su estatuto de
diplomáticos así lo denuncio un
colectivo de 500 representantes en una
tribuna de opinión en el periódico
francés le monde la semana pasada en la
que como los sindicatos de trabajadores
de la cancillería llamaron a la huelga
de este jueves ronda su consumo
hay una sensación sobre todo en las
generaciones jóvenes de que no se presta
la suficiente atención a las condiciones
en las que trabajando
son muchas horas y aveces no alcanzamos
a cumplir con nuestro deber con la
máxima calidad posible porque tenemos
demasiado trabajo que hacer
en medio de la tensión internacional por
la guerra en ucrania la nueva ministra
de exteriores francesa necesitará
resolver la situación una primera
reunión entre catering colonna y los
trabajadores está prevista para el 7 de
junio